So yesterday, Donald Trump flew to North Carolina.
I covered it live on our various life platforms.
The new strategy appears to be straight up
indefensible defense that are totally divorced
from reality.
No longer even trying to couch the lies as
being even remotely or plausibly believable.
Trump was asked about the fact, and it is
a fact that he's behind in the polls nationally
and he's behind in important states.
And Trump just responds, I'm winning everywhere.
And he doesn't just say I'm winning everywhere
and leave it at that.
Trump actually lists states in which he claims
he is winning, despite what the polls say.
Take a look at this.
Visibly sweaty Donald Trump lying uncontrollably
once again.
Poll numbers suffered in recent months because
of your handling on the candymaker.
Here now today.
What's your plan going forward to prove to
Americans that you're the right person?
I think the poll numbers are very good.
The poll numbers we have a very good were
leading in North Carolina.
We're leading in Pennsylvania.
We're leading in Arizona.
Our numbers were leading in Arizona.
Were leading nicely in Florida.
I think our poll numbers are very good.
We're leading substantially in Georgia.
I mean, we get a lot of suppression polls.
We get a lot of fake polls, just like we have
fake news.
That's a terrible thing.
When you look at it.
But I had the same thing four years ago.
Now I've said, listen, today I've spent what
a bunch of the show reminding you Trump can
win.
Yeah.
Trump can win.
But here he is simply lying.
Poll numbers are good.
I'm leading in North Carolina.
He says he's leading in Pennsylvania, Arizona,
Florida and Georgia substantially.
The numbers right now averages in these states
are that Biden is up by four in Arizona.
Biden's up eight in Florida, which is incredible.
Trump is up by three in Georgia.
I don't know that it's overwhelming, but he's
up by three.
Biden's up eight in Michigan.
Biden's up three in North Carolina.
Biden's up seven and six in Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin, respectively.
So, of course, Donald Trump is lying.
But my question is, is this a good strategy
for Trump from the standpoint of get out the
vote?
And what I mean by that is if Trump's followers
believe Trump, the polls are fake and Trump's
winning, aren't they less likely to go out
and vote?
In other words, if you want Trump to win,
are you not more motivated to get out and
vote?
If you believe Trump may actually lose your
state now, I'm not giving them advice.
I'm thinking out loud.
Wouldn't Trump be better off saying something
like, we are taking the campaign seriously
in every state?
I plan to fight for every state because I
think I'm better for the people of all of
these states than my opponent.
Rather than saying we're actually winning
because it seems to me that saying we're actually
winning might suppress his own turnout.
I just don't understand the strategy.
And maybe it's not really a strategy.
It's just Trump's personality, Trump's narcissism
and Trump's delusions of grandeur that force
him to do this.
Now, later on, during the same event, Trump
hilariously says, how could I be losing Florida?
There's a whole bunch of boat owners in a
manmade lake that have Trump flags that they
are flying proudly.
Take a look.
When you look at Florida as an example, you
have thousands of boat out about boats, out
of the ocean, out of the intercoastal.
You look at other states where likewise you
have thousands of boats and they're all waving
the Trump sign Trump pen sign and they're
so proud.
Thousands and thousands.
You've seen it where you have bikers for Trump
with lines at a miles long on highways going
along on weekends.
I think there's more spirit now than there's
ever been for my campaign.
And that includes 2016, where obviously there
was great enthusiasm, great spirit.
We had great spirit.
I think there's more today because what we've
done, nobody's ever done before.
Nobody has ever rebuilt the military.
Cut taxes the most in our history, created
the greatest economy we've ever had.
The focus on bikers and boaters is just weird.
Maybe Trump doesn't understand polls versus
anecdotes.
I don't know.
One other key moment from this short question
and answer period that Trump did, and this
is a common thing.
Trump has brought back the Corona virus press
briefings, but he takes very few questions,
very, very few.
And of course, he never actually answers them.
Trump was asked, you know, when you spoke
to Vladimir Putin earlier today.
Did you bring up the Russian bounty's?
And of course, Donald Trump would not say
he did talk with Russia because he.
Susan and I wanted to ask if you did bring
it up.
The reports of.
Russia having to use on our soldiers and we
discussed, but we had plenty of discussion
and I think it was very productive place.
Trump offhandedly just dismisses it as I don't
talk about what we've discussed.
That's not true.
I mean, often you do.
And often there are readouts where we learn
what it was that was discussed.
And in this case, Trump isn't saying what
I'm hearing is, no, Donald Trump did not call
Vladimir Putin out about Russian bounties,
obviously.
And that story has been very well buried.
I've posted on Twitter a few times over the
last month.
What exactly happened with the Russian bounty
stories?
The responses from the right tend to be something
about a conspiracy.
I don't know.
It's Obama committed some crime.
Tends to be the response, not very coherent.
But the story has actually been successfully
buried.
And we are going to make an effort not to
allow that to persist.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
I really am overdue for a new urban garden
tour.
My zucchinis are out of control.
I've got 10 inches, eight inches out there.
I've actually already picked one.
It's crazy.
Mike CUCs are starting to come in.
My tomatoes are like nothing anybody in my
backyard has ever seen before.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman for
the latest from the Urban Garden.
If you care about that sort of thing.
Otherwise, right after this short break.
Coleman Hughes joins me next for what I am
sure will be
a
very interesting discussion.